and I'm going to welcome you to this
video comma in the house this black guy
who plays c-3po this a guy way of always
have black somehow or am I wrong with
this this notion I somehow feel okay
let's have a look I've got 19 black
games and 11 white game so in this case
there is really a gap there so um yeah I
don't really have a good line against
III mmm i must be totally honest there
with you I've come on explain this again
i know it is boring with i need to look
up something against against c3 so what
am I doing here at Teague takes with the
Queen's and Jan your chicks yeah this is
a good we should be 3 is a bit more
interesting then be sure to I'm e 2 well
you have the check here and before isn't
that a good man okay yeah but I can take
here right why not
Wow adept at deadlines paid off it's
extremely boring and you win in 11 moves
that's funny you could have taken on
before they're right i mean it looks
like i'm fine then let's play really
funny and our switch turns you on yeah
this is not good young because of a
check but he really should've thought
for a moment then we can still take him
this must be it must be okay for me and
threatening here here and a 2 eggs so
definitely white is is not not great
here but it's still a game night before
yeah that looks sensible yeah tough to
say what to do just grab me to grab a 2
i think i'm very tempted to take this
one gives the night of stable so I'm
just upon a better day look at surprised
that the engine is just on 0.5 this wide
really enjoy compensation here maybe you
get something against those pawns anyway
it's preferable to the sandwich just use
on the spot I think here why does should
probably play Knight c3 as the engine
suggest I think it something like that
is going to be on the board then the
likelihood of the draw is very high in
this line which is that again see 3 i
only have somewhat half line see I don't
have anything great and all greater
things that actually comfortable playing
against a good player will you need to
look look up something there the c5 line
is kind of boring but it is a simple
recipe if you don't just want to play
something that's easier that doesn't
not bad to do yeah until here in the
actual game jam which is the four-piece
yeah okay guys thanks for watching